E aí
e nos próximos 18 minutos eu vou
esforçar-me ao máximo para vos mostrar
que o número este palco pelo menos não
merece mais do qualquer um de vocês e eu
sou psicóloga humanitária já esteja em
vários países e eu estive na
guiné-bissau com três crianças a
morrerem a minha frente todos os dias
estive na Venezuela entre os estágios na
lista estruturados por regime estive no
campo de memória na Grécia duas vezes
atender menor esfaqueadas todas as
noites sempre que eu tentava falar sobre
isto nas redes sociais ou nos Mira
convencionais sempre que eu tentava
mostrar o que se passa no terreno e
mostrar como é que todos podemos ajudar
eu tinha mais ou menos três tipos de
reação primeira é só um herói a
gigantesca maioria das pessoas reais com
elogio ou enaltecimento pessoal usa
palavras como o teu altruísmo a tua
Entrega a Tua humanidade ou até Betty
que tu devias dar um grupo muito mais
pequeno mas bastante mais quente pessoas
perguntava O que é que se passa ou seja
queria saber mais sobre as pessoas
estavam no terreno sobre a
e como é que a situação chegou àquele. O
que é que tinha acontecido até então e o
que é que provavelmente iria acontecer a
seguir e em grupo ínfimo minúsculo
pessoas perguntavam como é que eu posso
ajudar queria saber como é que podia
participar a partir daqui para mudar as
coisas lá
e sempre foi a minha atenção inverter
estas proporções e inverter as terapia e
hoje estou aqui mais uma vez para isso
O que começa com uma ideia muito simples
mas extremamente polêmica a maior parte
das pessoas é altruísta a maior parte
das pessoas têm comportamentos altruísmo
se não só quer ajudar os outros como
realmente se mexe e ajuda e não ajuda
mais essencialmente por duas razões ou
porque a distância mais ou seja não sabe
o que está o que está acontecendo no
terreno ou não sabe o que está
acontecendo no fundo da rua de uma forma
impactante ou opções a menos não sabe
como é que pode ajudar não se sente
ficar a promover essa mudança
bom E porque é que eu digo que a maior
parte das pessoas têm comportamentos
altruístas frequentes primeiro duas
noções quando fala um comportamento
altruísta é um comportamento que tende a
beneficiar mais o outro do que a mim mas
como é praticamente certo na literatura
qualquer comportamento altruísta que eu
tenha tenho benefício para mim que seja
psicológico social e espiritual moral ou
até físico então onde é que eu encontro
evidência fazer com a maior parte das
pessoas altruísta e eu podia começar com
o comportamento infantil crianças de 18
meses já larga o brinquedo Como estão a
brincar e Vão apanhar a caneta que o pai
deixou cair crianças com três anos se
virem um adulto outra criança
industriais quer chorar ou tentar
consolar poder falar de comportamento
materno as mães têm dezenas ou centenas
de pensamentos todos os dias que
beneficiam muito mais os filhos do que
elas próprias podia falar dos nossos
pais ou irmãos um avós ou até amigos que
tem muitos comportamentos que beneficiam
mais em nós do que eles eu podia falar
dos cuidadores informais
e são filhos e filhas companheiros e
companheiras que deixaram o trabalho
para cuidar de alguém que está acamado
ou está denunciado e reparem e eu nunca
fiz nada disto nunca fiz nada
remotamente semelhante a isto senão uma
pausa na vida normal para fazer uma
missão Isto é a vida normal dessas
pessoas e vocês dizem pronto nisso é
altruísmo com os nossos e tu ajuda de
estranhos mas nós temos formas de medir
altruísmo constantes uma delas chama-se
o dogue index é um índice mundial já
aferido a mais de 10 anos em 140 países
uma mostra que tende a ser
representativa cinco biliões de pessoas
e quais são os resultados Metade das
pessoas do mundo ajudou Um Estranho no
último mês Metade dos adultos do mundo
ajudou os trens no último mês o que quer
dizer que metade de vocês já acaba aqui
é um quinto das pessoas do mundo uma em
cada cinco pessoas fez voluntariado no
último mês quer dizer que deixou a sua
vida normal e foi tentar aumentar o
bem-estar de um perfeito estranho sem
qualquer remuneração sim porque nós não
trabalho humanitário muitas vezes temos
que mineração
e isso é o que eu vejo muitas vezes não
só por contacto com muitos voluntários
mas porque tem um grupo de ativismo cá e
vejo comportamento altruísta com
estranhos em todas as profissões que nós
fazemos abaixo-assinados nós fazemos e
todos os eventos são manifestações em
todas as campanhas de angariação de
fundos nós fizemos uma este ano no auge
do confinamento aqui em Portugal em
março no auge do lei off nós lançamos
uma campanha de angariação de fundos
para o anos as médicas nos campos de
refugiados da Grécia EA resposta Foi
incrível nos com um vídeo uma canção e
dos testemunhos no terreno conseguimos
fazer aquilo que eu falava há pouco
diminuímos a distância mostramos o que
passava no terreno de uma forma
impactante iremos opções de ação podemos
entender as pessoas que uma doação
monetária podia salvar vidas do convite
nos campos na Grécia
o que vocês dizem pronto material 3M
fácil de fazer porque eu não tenho
certez fã não se tem que sair daqui não
é nada a herói
é realmente a heróis ou seja realmente a
atriz de altruísmo extraordinário a
pessoas que se atiram ao mar entram
edifícios em Chamas para salvar a vida
de outros e muitas vezes quando a sua
própria integridade física em risco as
pessoas cansam entrevistadas depois
disto dizem que não pensaram na
fronteira não me liberaram foi um
impulso foi automático foi um reflexo
mas não é disse também falar aqui hoje
Isso realmente é raro primeiro que não
muitas oportunidades de demonstrar Ainda
bem e segundo porque realmente nem toda
a gente faria mas não é isso que nós
fazemos nas missões é isso que nós vemos
nas missões em absolutamente todas as
missões humanitárias 12 tive eu vi ato
de altruísmo extraordinário por pessoas
que estavam desesperadas ou então
incrivelmente favorecidas no ciclone em
Moçambique e ouvir alguém entrar no
edifício que tem aquela pesado para
levar um estranho até o nosso Hospital a
2 km de distância no campo de memória eu
vi alguém a defender um estranho de um
esfaqueamento e levar até a nossa
Clínica e o outro está aqui sou eu
e os meus atos de altruísmo são comuns
são frequentes e são banais e ainda bem
quer dizer que toda a gente não só tem
que a precisar de fazer mas realmente
faz E porque é que são mais comuns com
os nossos
a causa da distância não só física mas
também psicológica quando eu estou Cara
a Cara quando eu vejo quando eu falo
quando eu sinto quando eu cheiro Alguém
então a minha parte emocional sol e as
probabilidades de aumentar o meu
comportamento altruísta também sobem é
por isso que é muito melhor do contares
uma história uma narrativa do que dá uma
informação há uma estatística muito
melhor do que isso é uma imagem
é melhor que a minha imagem é um vídeo
bom e muito melhor que um vídeo é ir lá
se tu fores lá então já não são Os
migrantes é Fátima que chora com as mãos
na cara porque o filho morreu na
travessia do Mediterrâneo é o mar que
não tem piada nenhuma mas cozinha muito
bem se tu fores lá já não é o Patronato
que explora os trabalhadores é o Carlos
não conseguiu manter a pequena e média
empresa teve de pedir os funcionários e
não consegue manter a filha no qual é se
tu fores lá não é o beneficiário RS
surfista é a Carla que já não tem idade
nem competências profissionais para
arranjar trabalho facilmente
o quanto vezes o outro contra o
individualismo expõe o personalizas
Deixa de ser um grupo passa a ser uma
pessoa é que nós chamamos efeito de
vítima identificável mas como é que
consigo ter este efeito a pessoas em
pessoas estão milhares de quilómetros
tu estás À Espera De conseguir através
das mídias convencionais pode não
resultar primeiro que ele tem limites
tem limites na linha editorial tem
limites de formatos Tem um limite de
tempo de exposição tem uma coisa que se
chama fadiga midiática um assunto depois
de ser transmitido muitas vezes é
emprestado tem outro limite que somos
nós nós temos o poder de ditar a agenda
dos media para vencer mais uma das
coisas fazemos no rabo através das
nossas campanhas online ou do nosso
eventos nós tentamos por um assunto na
mesa e depois está na mesa é muito mais
fácil para os media irem lá buscar e
acreditem que a muita gente nos mente
stream está desejos pegar neste assuntos
só precisa de massa crítica suficiente
para lá buscar luz eu deixo aqui uma
lista de algumas fontes de informação
e tem mecanismos de qualidade mas que
são enviadas para crises humanitárias o
que eu quero dizer com isto é que tu
queres ver o outro vai ter que procurar
informação ativamente mas muito mais
difícil do que isso Vais ter de procurar
ativamente informação que diz confirma a
tua porque no mundo polarizado entre nós
e eles tu achas que eles moram numa
bolha então Muito provavelmente Nós
também moramos no mundo polarizado entre
nós e eles tu tens de falar com eles se
quer realmente mudar as coisas essas
dicotomias nós e eles temos várias
presentes na cabeça a damos de valores
diferentes até o nome do próprio dia se
tiveres no trabalho é dicotomia patrão e
empregado é mais saliente do quando vais
para casa e se querem mais Pais e Filhos
pensem Porque isto é benfiquista homem e
mulher português francês pensa em quem a
no teu carro durante o acidente e quem é
no outro carro e essas dicotomias tem
consequências importantes no nosso
comportamento e eu empate isso mais que
os nossos Eu comunico melhor com os
nossos eu perdoo mais os nossos beijo
mais qualidades positivas nos nossos e
ajuda
e eu considero que eles são mais
homogêneos tendencialmente mais
negativos e não são prioridade na minha
ajuda
é mas as boas notícias é que nós
conseguimos inverter essas categorias
facilmente pensa não precisa benfiquista
hoje o Porto Benfica o nós é porto ele
tá Benfica ou encontrar mas para semana
joga a seleção ou não são portugueses
desculpa e eles é franceses pensa nas
trevas de Natal da primeira grande
Guerra Mundial soldados alemães e
Soldados Aliados posaram as armas
comeram juntos tocaram missa juntos
trocaram presentes trocaram moradas
Prometeram visitar são uns aos outros
avisavam são uns aos outros né que a
poderia cair para ninguém ficar ferido e
foi preciso que oficiais de ambos os
lados ameaçassem com tribunal para que
voltassem aos combates o nosso e ele
deixou de ser humano de Aliados para se
você ser saudades e oficiais eu não
quero com isto dizer quando faço missões
me sinto de novela não me sinto que
nesse mas encontro pontos em comuns
suficiente em comum para criar um nós
mais alargado aumentar a minha empatia e
consequentemente altruísmo mas empatia
tem consequências negativas e nós nunca
falamos sobre isto não falamos nas
palestras
a psicólogos e
a atriz conselhos importantes antes de
falar sobre isso empatia emocional
empatia cognitiva e comportamental de
vista empatia emocional acontecendo isso
um bocadinho com outra pessoa está a
sentir e quando está desesperado e
sempre um bocadinho tristeza irão ser a
quando vejo alguém extasiada e sente-se
um bocado de alegria contentamento
empatia cognitiva é Tu colocaste no
lugar da outra pessoa tentar perceber a
situação dela através das referências
dela e a comportamento pró-social
altruísmo é ação at the chest e ajudar a
outra pessoa e é isso que nós ficamos
aumentar aqui hoje então a empatia tempo
a sequências negativas empatia emocional
tem consequências negativas por exemplo
demasiado empatia emocional não permite
altruísmo ficar demasiado agitada com o
surgimento de outra pessoa não consegue
organizar irá ajudá-la empatia emocional
enviesada pode ser tremendamente justa
que eu fiz uma criança a ser atropelada
pode esperar a sua agressividade contra
o condutor sem culpa nenhuma servir as
pessoas numa fila de espera vão gabinete
médico se uma
é tipo tu me batizar ficar mais passar
lá à frente sem critério o que é
tremendamente injusto para os outros
nove empatia emocional tem limites que
ele consegue sentir a dor de mil pessoas
de uma forma mil vezes mais forte que a
dor de uma empatia emocional e focada
depende as tuas experiências tu és do
porto se calhar a questão dos sem-abrigo
do Porto é muito mais sensível para ti
Do Que Os migrantes de leads se tivesse
no Iêmen se calhar a mortalidade
infantil no Iêmen é muito mais sensível
para ti porque na guiné-bissau
a empatia emocional e como holofotes
colega coloca algumas pessoas na luz mas
deixa uma multidão na escuridão e mesmo
nível profissional uma pessoa não
procura em para ter um sinal um doente
condições ruins está desesperado não
está procura não quer encontrar um
médico e também sinto alguma dor física
e acontecer pelo contrário quero um
médico psicólogo advogado ou até um
amigo que demonstrar empatia cognitiva
que demonstre que está a perceber o que
a pessoa está a passar mas que se
mantenha a calma para ser eficaz na
ajuda eu não estou a dizer para deixarem
ir para tirar emocionalmente primeiro
que não é possível estou só chamar a
atenção para as consequências negativas
porque assim aumentamos a probabilidade
de ocorrer comportamento altruísta
pronto só dei algumas dicas para
diminuir a distância o nosso e eles e
para termos sinal lado negativo como dar
informação como dar opções depois de
ação mas e vocês vocês também tem o eles
vocês também tem as bolsas haters às
vezes não chamar atenção para o assunto
Oi guarda e discorda fortemente como é
que fazemos como é que estamos com isso
a diminuir a distância fala cara a cara
ou seja faz na mesma teu post Mas pode
responder com uma mensagem politicamente
incorreta para não dizer insultos ao que
parece ignorante um insensível não
responda sem público respondem privado
ou melhor convida para tomar um café ou
para jantar ou melhor ainda não responde
se quer ouvir tenta perceber onde é que
vem essa opinião
de 80 partir genuinamente vai interação
com a criança que essa pessoa tem alguma
coisa para te ensinar a ti
a procura terreno comum como ativista
toda a gente quer ajudar outras pessoas
nos querem ajudar o nós e tu para
aumentar a chamar atenção Para um eles e
essa pessoa não quer dizer que seja
insensível dentro do grande bolo procura
uma fatia mesmo que tem a ver com outras
coisas em concordem anos e mantenho o
foco na ação no que é que vamos fazer
porque se tiver estão debate abstrato
Então as opiniões começam a deixar de
ter peso começam a polarizar e torna-se
mais importante ter razão do que o que é
que vamos fazer deixa ser importante que
é que vão fazer com a fatia minúscula e
passa a ser mais importante quem é que
merece o bolo inteiro mostra os
resultados que pessoas comuns tem ajudar
outras pessoas comuns e mostra o que tu
fazes e faz mas faz mesmo porque que tu
fazes tem muito mais impacto com aquilo
que tu dizes por exemplo Médicos Sem
Fronteiras São uma energia humanitária
internacional no menu dão 11 milhões de
consultas adultos número incontável de
vidas salvas é tudo realizado por
é mas sobretudo é tudo financiado por
pessoas comuns 95% de financiamento
vende cidadãos privados é alguém que
está em Lisboa no porto São Petersburgo
em Nova York amsterdão no Rio a salvar a
vida alguém que está na África do Sul no
Congo ou na Venezuela ou na Índia e
aquilo que um parente se achas que
sempre fizeste para o terreno mas não
tens perfil manda mensagem nas redes
sociais porque a muito mais preciso que
aqueles que tu achas muito mais ou menos
justifica eles tu achas que é que a
dentro porque lá fora
e eu não tenho a menor a missão de
relacionar o teu comportamento só com
uma toque eu já sei que tu és altruísta
muito pro vavelmente altruísta com
estranhos e só estou a tentar insuflar
um bocado mais as velas do teu barco e
fazer-te entender que quando ele parte
Tu levas muita gente contigo obrigado
[Aplausos]
E aí